to treat to be back again so I will take
a couple minutes to introduce myself
first of all it's nice to see a couple
of familiar faces in the audience so I
am with whole foods market my title is
really eCos are and regional forager
just like it says on the board there
I've been with whole foods market now
for 17 years actually just had my
anniversary last month for 17 years and
it's been quite a ride and I'll tell you
a little bit about that but I did
promise Gordon that I would say a little
bit about my title of EKOS are which
well I did not start out as the egos are
at whole foods market i started out i
came into the company from a completely
different field i was in health care and
hospital administration for a long time
before I made the career switch to whole
foods market into retail and I did that
for a variety of reasons one of which is
that my hospital was closing and they
were downsizing and so I took the
opportunity to do something that I toyed
with doing for a very long time which is
getting back into retail because I grew
up in retail and I really love that
environment and you know have always
just loved being a person who works in
retail so it's a great opportunity 17
years ago to just completely hop out of
Social Work hospital administration and
then do a whole foods market so when I
joined the company i went into
leadership and for the first eight years
i was with the company i basically ran a
couple of our stores in the boston area
and then about 10 years ago the
leadership team in the north atlantic
region which is New England basically
said you know we have this core value
that we talked about a lot which is
caring for our communities
ironmen it's our fifth core value fact
is we don't do a very good job of that
and you knew they'd start doing a good
job with it so the decision was made at
that point in time to create and
dedicate a position to taking care of
the environment I thought I would be
competing with a whole bunch of my
friends and colleagues for that job and
it turned out I was the only one who
applied for it so it was disappointing
and fortuitous for me at the same time
so when it came time to decide what we
were going to call me I decided that you
know what the company really needed was
an eco czar and I said that's my title
that's what I'm going to be we had a
little back and forth about that my
direct boss who was the president of the
North Atlantic region said no you're not
going to be the eCos are and I said well
yeah I am and he said okay I'll give you
a choice you can have either the title
or a salary I took the title our CEO who
hopefully some of you have read about as
quite a character his name is John
Mackey CEO and founder of whole foods
market he hates my title and he says you
know Lee azhar has absolute power and
you have absolutely none when I say
that's true John that's very true but
that forces me to be really strategic to
get throwing things done and so for the
last 11 years or so I've been playing at
that I've been very strategic because
I've been doing things that really
needed to get done and in our industry
they weren't always the top priority for
people things like pushing towards zero
waste
we're grocery chain you know we were
there to sell food to people and and I
think we do a really good job with that
you know diverting waste is not the
number one priority for everybody
although it's a very important goal for
everybody but I get to be the one that
kind of stewards that and shepherds it
along and so it's an honor and it's also
the title is a good way to open do it
and get people to laugh a little bit
lighten up so that's the answer Gordon
that's where eCos are fits in I'm going
to talk to you tonight about getting to
zero waste in the retail food
environment I am going to try to focus
as much as I possibly can on what
happens in our world in the produce
department and it's easy for me to do
because that's where I started with
whole foods market when I first joined
the company I came in as a produce team
leader and I didn't really know where
else to get involved and I needed to get
started somewhere so I was asked well
what part you know what department of
whole foods market they feel most
comfortable and I you know having come
from an agricultural community and
feeling really connected to farmers and
and agriculture and the produce in
general i said i think the produce
department swear i should start my first
day on the job I started to see how much
food waste was being thrown away in the
produce department and it shocked me and
I saw that happening for a while and
started to think about it and schemer
that I am I said well you know all this
stuff is being thrown away and I'm a I'm
gonna I'm a gardener I'm in agriculture
so why don't I figure out a way to drive
around and collects all this stuff and
you know take it somewhere and
turn it in the compost and sell it so
that was my first scheme I didn't
actually do that but I thought it was a
good idea and there's possibilities
there anyway here's the food recovery
hierarchy from the EPA Environmental
Protection Agency has anybody seen this
before been out for a little while now
so I'll just walk you through it really
quickly at the very top of the hierarchy
you see source reduction reducing the
volume of surplus food generated next
down is feeding hungry people donating
extra food to food banks soup kitchens
and shelters and then you go to feeding
animals diverting food scraps to animal
feed fourth down industrial uses such as
providing waste oils for rendering and
fuel conversion and food scraps for
digestion to recover energy down near
the bottom you get to composting well I
happen to think that's a pretty
important thing to be doing but I also
agree that there are a whole lot of
other more important things to do with
food waste before you get to that point
and I'm going to talk about that as well
and then at the very bottom one that we
all need to avoid at all possible cost
is to allow food or any organic material
to get into a landfill for a whole bunch
of reasons we can't afford to waste it
no matter if it's scraps or otherwise
and we can't afford the buried in the
ground because it becomes methane gas
and methane gas is the most potent
greenhouse gas there is so really at all
costs we need to be avoiding letting
food get into a landfill or an
incinerator for that matter here's my
goals for the evening I hope they're
going to be yours as well I want to ask
more questions of you guys and I really
have answers for i hope you'll do the
same thing this is a process of you know
taking a look at what we're doing and
finding better ways to do it and smarter
ways to do it really I want to get us
all pissed off about what the situation
is with food waste what are we doing
wasting food we should be asked
so that a third of the food that's
produced on this planet is wasted thrown
away that's a crime I want to introduce
the concept of waste as food I want to
begin to erase from all of our minds the
concept of waste all together that's a
word that we need to eliminate from our
vocabulary I've done a pretty good job
of that myself and I really encourage
you guys to be thinking about that as
well there's no such thing as waste
everything that's waste is food for
something else and I also want to remind
us that there's no such thing as a way
anybody here familiar with Barry
commoner Gordon yes so Barry commoner
was a personal hero of mine on the first
earth day he came to my college and he
gave a talk and that's the first time
that I've ever heard is four or five
rules of ecology depending on how you
count but one of those was this concept
that there's no such thing as a way we
really have to get rid of the idea that
you can throw something somewhere and
it's going to go away it doesn't it's
still there we still need to deal with
it so that's another concept I'd like
you guys to be thinking about
particularly when you leave here tonight
you're not throwing anything away just
doesn't happen what's the scope of the
problem with food waste in the UK
retailers and wholesalers produce about
1.7 million tons of food waste a year in
the u.s. supermarkets restaurants and
convenience stores are throwing away
about 27 million tons of food annually
the dollar amount is significant but for
me that's not the biggest story the
biggest story is the tonnage but 41.9
billion dollars a year in the US alone
and on top of this and that's just again
that's just supermarkets retailers
restaurants convenience stores then we
get to what consumers waste and in the
US alone consumers wasted an additional
almost 26 million tons of food
annually when you think about those
numbers for me one of the things that's
really important to pay attention to is
the argument out there particularly by
those who are pushing the GMO issue
pretty hard that you know the reason to
genetically modified food is because we
don't have enough food we need more
production we need to really expand
production to me that's insane I mean
there's plenty of food being produced to
feed the world the problem is getting it
to where it needs to be destroyed
distributions a key part of this so food
waste is a global phenomenon it impacts
the environment in society in these four
key areas there's the energy used to
produce the food you know lots of
different ways that energy is used the
equipment the fuel that's involved the
you know all the different inputs that
go into raising food then there's the
food that's disposed of by retailers the
food that's wasted in households and the
energy that's used to dispose of the
food waste you know trucking food waste
burung at burning it all the
environmental hazards I spoke about
methane gas production that's just one
of them for land filling food waste so
there you know so many different reasons
why we really need to address this
problem fairly aggressively and by the
way I am comfortable I know we'll have a
Q&A time afterwards but I am comfortable
if anybody wants to stop me just throw
your hand up if you need more you know
if you need me to highlight anything
here or expand on yes
landfill yeah I'm sorry I didn't hear
where did that those numbers come from
these are all you know publicly
available I mean you can you can go to
any of the sites in fact I can give you
some links after the presentation to
wear this information is available to
you yes yeah that's yeah I think it's
more the former yeah yeah the amount of
food that you know represents in sales
on the shelf okay okay so and again
globally one-third of all food produced
is wasted in processing handling storage
sale preparation and serving of the food
again are we getting pissed off yet I do
pretty much every time I see this I'm
going to focus tonight on what we at
whole foods market are trying to do
about this situation I think we're in
some ways representative of the food the
retail food business but I think we may
be ahead of the curve in certain areas
so I'll try to highlight those for you
as well I do want to put something in
context though whole foods market is a
very very small company in our industry
you know we have 344 stores as of this
evening worldwide which means we have
you know a bunch in the United States we
have some in Canada and we have a
handful in the United Kingdom but
compared to say stop and shop which has
over 2,000 stores and you know the
parent company out hold has I think
thirty thousand or so stores globally
you know we're a real tiny operator at
the same time we have a lot of influence
in this industry and I think we have a
pretty strong halo effect so we try to
leverage that as much as we possibly can
to provide examples of things that we're
trying to move along so again one of the
you know the halo effect works well for
us and people do pay attention to
us and see us as leaders in a number of
fields when it comes to purchasing clout
we haven't got much and when it what it
takes to shift an entire industry is
often the scale of a stop and shop or
even larger so Walmart is a perfect
example of the you know the kind of
company that has such an incredible
powerful footprint that they can get
things done that often small players
like us can't unless we do it in
collaboration so that's another idea
that I want to plant tonight we can talk
about that more later but collaborating
with in our industry is one way to
really make some change happen okay so
here's one of the things that we try to
do and this is really at the very
beginning of our supply chain which is
we we try to concentrate on quality to
the deepest extent we possibly can so
that's our number one focus in the
produce world at all levels across the
company our number one core value it's
not in terms of importance but the way
we list them in our in our business our
number one core value is selling the
highest quality food that we can
possibly get our hands on and that
really does drive the bus for us you
know we try not to put anything on our
shelves that's really not the highest
quality quality in our market is
determined by taste the best way to
determine that is to try it appearance
and condition freshness traceability
knowing where and how the product was
grown which allows us to inform our
customers and some examples again
organic whole trade and local those are
very important qualities for our
customers in terms of our food and then
the USDA grade standards and
specifications which specify things such
as color size and form now how many of
you have been to a whole foods market to
a store anybody who hasn't been most of
you have been so you know when you walk
into our stores we put our produce two
apartments right up in front of the
store
it's usually the first department that
you walk into and we put a lot of effort
and i'm sure you'll know this and you'll
recognize that we put a lot of effort on
to making those pop making them really
stand out and wow you so you know
they're big displays they're very
abundant displays there you know the top
quality every single person in whole
foods market in the company is empowered
to go to a display and take off a
product that doesn't meet the highest
quality standards that's an expectation
for everybody who works in our business
that if you see something that's not top
quality it can't be on the shelf now in
my mind I can defend that and I can
argue that in terms of sales because our
customers are very particular about what
they buy and that's what they're looking
for you'll see if you come into the
store that people will root around
through the displays looking for the
perfect tomato the perfect peach you
know the perfect pair and they'll leave
the ones behind that they don't think
are that perfect example so you know we
want to provide that for them at the
same time that involves a lot of
handling it involves a lot of bruising
and product does get damaged in that
process I can't tell you how many times
I've seen that beautiful apple display
you know mrs. McGillicutty comes in and
she takes the bottom Apple and the whole
thing ends up on the floor that's a
whole display of apples that's pretty
much not for sale anymore so you know
it's a double-edged sword for sure we
sell a lot of beautiful produce and
there's a lot that's left behind because
it you know it ends up not meeting that
top quality standard now when I say left
behind I don't mean wasted and i'll talk
more about that so before it ever gets
to us at the very beginning of the
supply chain we have a field team that's
out in the fields with the growers it's
a fairly extensive team this is a seven
of our crew it's not the entire crew but
we have people who are actively out in
the fields with the growers day in and
day out all over the world and their job
is to you know really inspect for
quality so here's what they're looking
for when
out in the field these are the key
components of what we call whole foods
produce produce inspection they're
looking at size they're looking at the
sugar content which is called bricks
don't know what that stands for maybe
somebody in here does I can't remember
but anyway that that's the term that's
used for sugar density they're looking
for the pressure inside of the fruit or
vegetable the temperature they're
looking for the cut and the taste
internally they're looking for how it
looks externally they're going by color
and they're going by weight there are a
couple of other things that they're
looking for as well but all of that
together goes into quality control so on
our end we're not purchasing produce
unless it meets all of these standards
and you know they have fairly rigorous
standards for for all of these different
you know variables in the inspection the
other thing that they're looking for by
the way and I didn't put a slide up
about this but they're looking very
carefully at what the social
considerations are you know the
well-being the growers what the field
conditions are for the growers how
they're being treated you know what
their living conditions are the
sanitation conditions you know
educational opportunities for their
children all those things are very
important part of a very important part
of what we look for when we're out in
the fields don't necessarily
specifically speak to quality but that's
part of our inspection as well so coming
back into the store level this is an
initiative that we started just this
past September because we were looking
at in the North Atlantic region again na
stands for North Atlantic and that's New
England we have 28 stores and four
facilities here in New England shrink is
waste basically that's the word that we
use for whatever doesn't get sold that
you know comes into our stores as
product and goes out the back door not
for sale not for donation not for
sampling or demoing but just as pure
waste so we really wanted to get
handle on shrink across the board not
just in produce and this past September
we put into place a shrink get a
reduction initiative and i'm going to
show you what that looks like so our
goal was to reduce shrink by nine basis
points across the region total regional
shrink nine basis points a huge portion
of total strength for us comes from
spoilage so again these are confidential
figures I'm going to show them to you
but if you would please don't broadcast
these outside of the room so we have
about 300 million dollars a year in
sales shrink is six point six four
percent of that or about almost twenty
thousand dollars 19.8 thousand dollars
and I mean yeah 19 million sorry 856
thousand dollars in shrink in a year so
our target was to get down to our
combined spoilage across the whole cut
the whole region would be a 50 basis
point reduction to save one and a half
million dollars so that's the number
that you see down at the bottom that's
our target here are the areas that we're
targeting trying to reduce shrink again
shrink being spoilage waste so at the
top you'll see it's a little hard to
read in yellow it says cull and product
rework program that's the biggest piece
of what our shrink reduction initiative
is about and what we're trying to do is
reduce by a million dollars just in that
area alone so per fiscal period we have
13 fiscal periods a year that would be
about 76 almost seventy seven thousand
dollars per fiscal period per store per
fiscal period would be about 2,700 2,800
dollars per store each fiscal period
that's what our goal has been okay these
other categories merchandising and
operations
team buying loss reporting and inventory
and receiving procedures I'll make a
contribution but you can see it's a much
smaller contribution than that
million-dollar contribution from a call
program I will say though the team
buying I want to talk about that for
just a minute we're very careful at
whole foods market about the way we buy
the food the you know the food that we
bring in for sale so I think we're more
rigorous about that then maybe other
grocers are other supermarkets are we
buy very tight as much as we possibly
can so even though you know again you
walk into the store you see this produce
department you know pilot high and watch
it fly anybody ever heard that term
before that's one that we use within the
business you know the idea that that's
really what customers are wowed by they
they see these huge beautiful piled
displays and you know they're so
impressed by that that they fill up
their grocery cart with it and you know
take it away and for the most part
that's really true that's that is what
people like to see and what they expect
from us but there's again there's all
that obvious you know shrink potential
from doing it that way so I want to give
you one example our Southern Pacific
region which is the LA area Orange
County down in that part of the country
a few years back they wanted to find out
a little bit more about how much they
were throwing away from the produce
department so they started to do what's
called waste audits which basically is
dumpster diving you take your compost
dumpster you empty it out on the ground
you rake through it you put it in you
know put it in different piles and you
categorize it and one of the things they
learn from that is they were throwing
away an enormous amount of bananas
bananas are by the way that one of the
two top items that we sell in whole
foods market water being the other
believe it or not
so what the Southern Pacific region
found by doing that waste audit is that
they were throwing away in the region
about a hundred thousand dollars worth
of bananas a fiscal period now that's
all an awful lot of bananas bananas are
pretty inexpensive so a hundred thousand
dollars per fiscal period in bananas
alone the other drawback that I see your
hand I'll get to you in one second the
other drawback to that is that bananas
unlike many other produce items there's
not a whole lot else you can do with
them you know when it comes to trying to
find other uses for them there's only so
much banana bread you can make and other
than that there's not a whole lot left
but not a muffin so so what they learned
from that process is that they could cut
back on their purchases have bananas by
about a hundred thousand dollars of
fiscal period end up saving you know
millions of dollars just by doing that
go ahead and amount of sales or is that
a unit of dollars it's yeah it's a
dollar miss oh yeah believe it or not
huge so we're we're determined to take a
million dollars of waste away and call
and product reworking let me see if my
next slide explains that it's not i'll
go into it yeah so calls and rework why
are we focusing on this obviously it's
going to reduce waste in the waste
stream it's going to improve quality on
the sales floor help our team members
focus on a quality presentation let me
say a little bit more about this so
calling is basically the process of
taking any product from those displays
that i talked about earlier you know
those beautiful big abundant piled up
displays any product that's there that
doesn't meet the highest quality
standard you know that's bruised or
damaged in some way or is something that
our customers are not going to buy
taking it out of those displays if we
can if we can possibly rework it doing
that or
or if not getting that to a different
Department that can use it rather than
wasting it so reworking if you anybody
in here ever worked in a produce
department at all yes so you know that
one of the things you do with greens is
you can refresh them you know when
they're out on a display and they start
to look look a little limp and a little
worn that doesn't mean that they're
wasted it means that if you trim the
bottom and put them back in water they
come back to life again so that's one
example of reworking where you can
actually get a couple of days of extra
shelf life sometimes certain products
just by doing that just by trimming off
the base you know that with flowers you
know when you buy a fresh bunch of
flowers and then you take it home you
cut off an inch or so the bottom of the
stems put it in water after a couple of
days if you do that again you can extend
the life of the flowers same kind of
principle so you know we try to again we
try to rework as much food as we
possibly can by doing that and we tried
to call as much as we can and keeping
the focus for our team members on that
you know we want the top quality we want
the highest quality product on our
shelves that we can possibly have that
doesn't mean that the other stuff is not
perfectly edible and perfectly fine it
again mostly is a sales driven kind of a
variable which means that our customers
probably won't buy it if it doesn't meet
their standards but again doesn't have
anything to do with whether it's tasty
or edible or any of that stuff for
safety yeah
how
it's a great question and I don't have a
number or a statistic to apply to it but
I do know that we believe that our art
then we show this and we talked to our
customers and our team members about it
that the you know the product that we go
through and rework and and you know
maintain that quality standard lasts
longer at home for the customer so and a
lot of the traditional or the
conventional supermarkets if you buy a
head of lettuce for example you know you
take it home and in a day or so it
there's not much there left to work with
we see that we get longer shelf life and
longer keeping time at home so I think
that's where the difference is I think
we put a lot more into taken care of it
on the shelf so that you know it just
has longer legs when it gets home so let
me go back to this how are we going to
do this call program so the best way for
us to do almost anything in whole foods
market is to talk to the people who have
their hands on it every day so when we
started the call program we went to our
team members on the floor and we talked
to them about you know what's the best
possible practice for getting this food
safely from the display shelf to another
department so that you know it can
somebody else can use it somebody else
can work with it and then we set up
processes based on what they told us we
really do believe that our team members
are the experts at this and you know we
really need to go by what's going to
work for them operationally if it
doesn't work for them if it's going to
take them a lot more time to get this
done if it's going to slow them down and
getting their work done it's probably
not going to work so the best way to put
anything into practice for us is really
to go by our team members wisdom and
really you know try to respect that as
much as we can and then again to set up
these processes to get the product
reworked as quickly as we can transfer
or no transfer this was a biggie for us
traditionally when we did this and we've
always done this you know this call
process so to some extent
and is focused away as we're doing it
now but when we did it we didn't apply
any value to it from department to
Department it was just kind of a
giveaway so for example if food was
being transferred from produce to our
prepared foods department the
expectation was there wouldn't be any
economic value to that at all there
wouldn't be any you know financial value
it would just go from one department to
another would be considered free food
basically for prepared foods that would
help them with their margins but it
wouldn't do anything for the protos team
we didn't really feel like that was
going to be the right kind of incentive
base for all the teams to participate in
this and put the work and energy into
making it happen so what we decided to
do again is to set up a well again we
got feedback from all of our teams all
of our product coordinators and our
product coordinators run their
departments within our region so there's
a produce coordinator or prepared foods
coordinator a bakery coordinate or a
meat coordinator they oversee all the
different teams and our stores you know
under that that umbrella so we talked to
all those people we decided to set up a
structured cost so that specific items
or specific categories would have some
economic value involved so for example
in the seafood department the seafood
team would get 350 a pound for any items
that ended up in the hot bar again if
you go into our stores you know you'll
find these you know ready to eat hot
foods you'll often find a fish item to
seafood item in there so you know 350 of
pounders with the seafood team gets from
the prepared foods team for that for
those items if it's going to go in the
chef's case which is a couple of steps
up from the hot bar that's really you
know the focal point of our prepared
foods department that's where all that
beautiful you know restaurant quality
food lives if the quality of the food
you know and and the value of the food
translated to that case then they would
be getting five dollars a pound for
those items ground beef from the meat
department across the board that was
going to be 250 a pound that
you know would go to the meat team if
it's going to prepared food so just a
few examples of that but again we wanted
to have a financial incentive in there
for the teams to do this as well and
then we establish some structured
procedures for how this was going to be
handled in between all the different
departments made sure that all the team
members knew how it worked posted signs
about it instructions trained them for
this so that everybody was pretty much
on board with it and this is an ongoing
process by the way again we just started
in September so we're still rolling this
out to some extent we're still tweaking
it but it's pretty much in place across
the board now this was one of the
solutions that again listening to our
team members how can we make this work
for you guys that may that's going to
give it the best possible shot at
success so we created a call cart
program so every store has every produce
department and prepared foods department
has a set of these carts call carts
they've got six pins six min seven mins
seven bins in them they're all clearly
labeled the card is clean it's organized
it's easy to use and it's labeled in
three different languages english
spanish and portuguese which is the you
know the vast majority of the languages
that our team members speak so pretty
much everybody gets it these are these
are these again are in each of our
produce departments on wheels so that
they can go from produce to prepared
foods in back we have a call board
that's hung in the back of the house
that's updated daily for everybody to
see we have dedicated one of our
associates door team leaders to follow
up on the call board daily so there's
accountability built into this thing the
associate store team leader is the
assistant store manager so at that level
that's the person who's responsible to
make sure that this program is working
in their store we measure the quantity
of the calls that are available and we
set targets by for each store prepared
foods has a rework master recipe list
that they establish so they basically
say here's our menu for
today here's what we're preparing what
do you guys have available that that
will fit into that menu what items can
we get from you you know peppers onions
radishes whatever it happens to be that
fits into the menu that we have for the
day we have a rework expert on each
prepared foods team so that person again
is is the designated person who figures
all this stuff out from the prepared
food side and decides what's needed and
how much of it is needed and then we
have a daily meeting between the produce
buyer and our prepared foods chef to
synchronize the use of the calls so that
again on the purchasing side the produce
people are bringing in enough for their
displays enough for their sales and
they're factoring in it's part of the
equation how much is going to end up
going to prepared foods Justin no and
that's a really good question that's
something I'll look into what's your
what's your assumption about that
I'm not sure it might it might have some
additional protection from the package
but the package is not going to be all
that substantial usually if it's in a
package if we're doing that ourselves
it's already been reworked once so one
example that would be our value-added
product everybody know you know we
basically in our stores we have
vegetables and fruits that have already
been prepped like salad bar stuff or
stuff that you know is kind of take home
convenience food so you know we'll
chopped peppers will chop onions will
package those so people can take them
home because it's been worked so much
already I'm not sure it would have the
same legs as fresh I would guess it
wouldn't have as much legs as fresh
onions or peppers would ya now it's a
really good question i don't i don't
know the answer I'll try to find out
though okay so everybody kind of with me
as far as we've gotten here and this is
a biggie we assign accountability so we
make sure that there's one go-to person
in every store that's our shrink captain
that's different from the associate
store team leader that's you know
they're just kind of overseeing the
process but at the end of the day we
want one person to go to and make sure
that they are working with this every
day that everybody knows their role
everybody knows what the
responsibilities are and the
expectations are and that this program
is being worked so this is each of our
28 stores and that's the person who's
been assigned to be the shrink captain
for each store so that's just one
example of what we're trying to do about
this food waste program again our target
is to reduce waste by a million dollars
a year just by this alone it's too soon
to tell how we're doing with that we
have some initial anecdotal evidence it
goes up and down doesn't surprise me
depending on the store depending on the
department you know how well people are
working the program but it's really been
designed
to work so I think it's more human
variability than it is the system that
we put in place we we really believe in
feeding people that's you know that's a
huge part of what our mission is so you
know we're a company that's here to feed
people that's you know that's an
incredibly important part of our mission
and to try to feed people healthy food
that's the other part of it you know
there are a lot of companies that are
feeding people but really whole foods
market is is dedicated to try and and
you know help people learn how to eat
healthier more nutritious food and have
you know a healthier life because of
that so whatever we can't sell either by
selling directly off the shelf or by
transferring to another Department to be
reworked into something different either
prepared foods or bakery or whatever
then we want to give it away and we have
a very aggressive program for getting as
much edible food as we possibly can to
food banks every day every store has a
food bank donation that tends to be a
lot of baked goods food banks are pretty
liberal about taking baked goods it's
fresh produce it's grocery items like
canned food what food banks are
reluctant to take from us or prepared
foods they're really kind of leery about
that for a number of different reasons
because they don't feel like they can
manage it you know safely to get it from
our store to the folks who need to eat
it it's just you know you've already cut
down significantly on the on the shelf
life when you cook food so again we try
to donate as much as we possibly can and
that varies again by store by community
what food banks are available we
sometimes deliver but that's pretty
challenging to do so mostly we rely on
food banks to be able to come and pick
up as much as we possibly can we are
determined by the end of this calendar
year to have metrics for every single
one of our store
in terms of how much they're donating to
food banks but just for an example in
2010 our six new york city stores
donated about 200 tons of food to
shelters and food banks the way the food
banks calculate that that's about 400
thousand meals so it's a pretty
significant amount and again you know we
really are very determined to try to do
as much of that as we possibly can a
couple of other ways that we're working
on the produce side in particular we've
just started a program literally just
started with the greater boston food
bank where our growers our produce
growers well let me talk about this for
a little bit produce growers has two
main streams for their product one of
which is wholesale well you know
wholesale or retail whatever you know it
could be their farm stand it could be a
CSA it could be wholesale you know
selling to businesses like ours what
they don't sell to businesses like ours
can go in a couple of different
directions it can go into food
production so maybe they sell it to you
know people who can the food or cook
with the food and package it in some way
or a lot of their food that doesn't meet
a high enough quality standard for any
of those streams can end up just getting
left in the field and passed over as
seconds usually what happens with that
is that it just gets plowed under
doesn't get harvested at all so there's
a fairly significant amount of food
that's being left in the field by the
growers that's perfectly edible just as
not going to meet the visual or you know
some other standard for getting into one
of those other streams so this new
program with the greater boston food
bank involves are picking up those
seconds you know the food that's being
left in the fields from our growers
either from them directly from the
fields or from their pack
sheds once the food gets the packing
sheds its been left behind in that
process again perfectly edible perfectly
safe just not meeting those top quality
standards visually more than anything
we're getting that collected and we're
getting that brought for donation to the
food banks now what they do with it you
know they process the food they they
freeze it they can it they store it they
serve it again people are being fed with
this food it's not going to waste we've
got a long way to go with this this is
in its infancy stages but what Whole
Foods is doing is you know we're we're
working with our growers we're providing
the transportation and we're getting it
to the folks who can continue to use it
to feed people we're also talking to our
growers about getting some of those
seconds directly to our prepared foods
teams rather than the food only coming
in to produce you know being sold in
produce and then rework through the call
program why not bring those seconds from
the fields directly to prepared foods
we're going to use it we're going to
cook it again top quality food you know
flavor-wise it's perfect it's just you
know it's not going to be left in the
field and plowed under it's going to
come in to feed people so that's another
program that we're developing feeding
animals again you know in the hierarchy
you saw that on the you know the food
waste hierarchy we try to do this as
much as we possibly can as well so just
a couple of examples here in st. Paul
Minnesota we have a number of stores
that are donating their you know their
food waste quote-unquote to local pig
farms in the Chicago area they are
partnering with the Lincoln Park Zoo for
meat and produce waste by the way not
far from here in Cheshire Connecticut we
have our central distribution center
that serves the North Atlantic in the
northeast regions of whole-food so it's
right in between the New York City New
Jersey and western connecticut stores
and our
North Atlantic which are New England
stores we have a huge amount of food
that comes into that facility including
our beef program so any beef that comes
in to the distribution center and
doesn't qualify you know isn't high
enough quality to go into our stores is
donated to a local zoo I don't remember
what so it is but it's one here in
Connecticut somewhere so these are just
a couple examples again we have stores
that have programs with rabbit farmers
where they're setting their greens aside
every day and that's being you know
that's going to the rabbits so again any
opportunity that we have to divert food
to animals we try to do that as well and
then technical processes that can use
some of that material instead of having
it go to waste so our stores all have
cooking oils in fri laters you know
there's a fairly significant amount of
our food that ends up getting cooked and
up until last year a lot of that oil was
going to you know companies that would
take it and use it to make various
different kinds of products not
necessarily ones you'd want to use but
we were paying to have it removed as a
waste product again just want to
emphasize this idea that there is really
no such thing as waste what we're doing
now in our North Atlantic region is
we're collecting all of the cooking oil
from all of our stores and from our
central commissary which is a huge
kitchen that we have in Everett
Massachusetts and we've installed a
generator and you see a picture of it
there this is the first generator of its
kind that's being used in the United
States at least we're doing more of this
in the UK that's running completely from
straight cooking oil it's not it's not
being chemically processed into you know
a different kind of a fuel it's a
straight cooking oil and it's powering
our entire commissary facility so we got
a lot of really interesting press about
this and again you know we used to pay
to have this removed his waist now it's
it's a great source of power anaerobic
digestion being used a lot in Europe and
in other parts of the world not so much
in this country yet basically involves
taking food processing it without oxygen
it's basically composting but in an
environment that doesn't have oxygen and
so it uses the methane gas it captures
the methane gas and that's turned into
fuel or it's turned into power and by
the way at the end of the day there's
also a byproduct of compost so you're
getting at least two very valuable
streams out of food waste one of which
is power or electricity or fuel and one
of which is compost for agriculture
again this is an up-and-coming
technology we're aware of several
different projects locally in fact one
in Connecticut that you know are in the
initial stages of getting funding and
getting permitting we're hoping that
this is going to become a bigger
opportunity for for food waste a couple
of interesting examples of things that
are going on with some other byproducts
of food or agricultural waste the USDA
has some really interesting packaging
initiatives going on and a couple of
examples that I have seen and heard
about recently one of which is using
chicken feathers to make packaging
another which is using fish fins to make
packaging you know that couldn't begin
to explain to you how they do that and
what technologies are involved but
that's what the feedstock is for
packaging and then again there's a
fairly significant industry out there
already that's making compostable
plastics from various food waste such as
potatoes sugar beets sugar cane things
like that anything that has sugar in it
can technically become a plastic the
best well-known one is called pla poly
lactic acid there's a company called
nature works you may or may not have
seen you know something about nature
works but they make a lot of clear
plastic packaging out
corn they have a huge facility out in
Iowa right in the middle of the corn
fields we at whole foods are not using
that material because ninety percent of
the corn that goes into that process is
genetically modified corn and we're
pretty clearly out there is not you know
supporting GMO technology so we don't
want to provide a market for that while
we're you know using that kind of
material but again it can be made out of
almost any plant material that contains
sugar so we're waiting for a non-gmo
source and there are some out there
already there's some material coming in
from Italy now that's made out of a
non-gmo maze that basically does the
same thing so that's pretty exciting
technology and then last but not least
composting for organics recycling so
that's me on the left with one of my
good buddies raking through the compost
heap I told you earlier that the best
way to figure out you know what's in
your waste stream is to dump it out and
break through it and characterize it
weigh it you know put it in piles so you
can really get a sense of what's in
there so that's the first step of the
process I tried have to do that in July
it's pretty ugly in July but it happens
sometimes again everything that is waste
is food for something else seventy
percent of our waste stream in whole
foods market is organic material or
compostable material between food waste
again try to keep that at a minimum but
that still ends up being a large part of
the seventy percent that we do consider
waste you know so that's food waste
that's wet paper waxed paper plant
materials things like that all of those
things that we generate that you know
again can either be buried in landfill
burned in an incinerator or go into
compost so for us and you know
we're an agriculturally based company
creating compost is really important
it's one of the most important things
that we do again back in 2003 when I
became the eCos are we weren't
composting at all all that stuff was
going into the landfill now I would say
that the vast majority of our stores are
at least diverting seventy to eighty
percent of their waste stream into
compost so it's a huge amount on the
average we're diverting about 10 tons a
week of organic material per store to
compost so on one hand that's you know
that's a really good thing from an
environmental perspective because it's
going to make this really highly
valuable agricultural commodity I'm
convinced that a huge percentage of that
material is still good you know
recoverable food and we just haven't
gotten good enough get it figuring out
how to do that so what I've been talking
about are the different ways up pardon
me that we're trying to recover as much
of that as we can but I know just from
looking into the composters that there's
still a lot of good food that's going in
there partly that's human nature and
it's part of the pace that our business
operates so when I look into the compost
container what I'll see in there is
packaged food because people don't take
the time to take it out of the packages
they don't feel like they have enough
time to open up the clamshell and empty
out the salad greens into the compost
bin rather than throw the whole thing in
the trash container so as good as we are
and I think we're really good at this
there's an awful lot of food that's
still ending up where it shouldn't yes
yeah yes or no so the easy part is that
we have so many really passionate
concern team members who come to work
for us so we're starting with a group of
people who want to do the right thing
and when we make it easy for them to do
that and we help them understand the big
picture or why it's important to do that
you know the economic side the
environmental side you know the climate
side of that because they're all wrapped
up in that they get it and then my big
part of my job is the eCos are has been
to create systems that make it as easy
as possible to do this so we do things
like we color code all of our sorting
been sorting mins we have essentially
three main streams that we deal with we
have organics which is green we have
recyclables which is blue and we have
landfill which is black or grey so in
every one of our departments there are
those three colored benz they're clearly
labeled they have signs on them that
explain and pictures whenever we can do
that that explain what goes in each Bend
and we very carefully trained our team
members about how to do that separation
we make those bins as easy to use and
easy to find as we possibly can so in
our in our kitchen areas where we do a
lot of the food prep will have a compost
bin in a trash bin side by side so a
team member doesn't have to take a
potato peel and walk from you know from
here ten feet away to put it in the
right bin it's right there with them
again color coating helps a lot so when
when our team members see green they
know that's food that's that's you know
organic material that's where it goes
when they see blue same thing you know
that's recyclable
and the the different languages helps a
lot you know so we really try to make
that azz multilingual as we can given
all that and the fact that they're
passionate people who want to do the
right thing there's still an awful lot
again human nature just you know people
are in a hurry they have a lot to do
there's a high expectation for
production and you know so it takes a
couple of extra seconds to take food out
of a package and you know put it into
two separate containers and i wish i
could say everybody was so passionate
that they do the best they can every
single day but most times they do not
all the time
not really and you know if you can help
me figure out a way to do that i would i
would appreciate it and love it you know
beside the you know the higher value of
taking care of the environment again
which people in it does motivate our
people we have a green bucks program in
our stores so people you know if a team
members see somebody doing a good job
they can just give them a five-dollar
$10 green bucks card which will buy them
lunch or buy them dinner so we have
those kinds of you know incentives in
other aspects of our company we have
financial incentives that mean a lot to
people for example just i'll go off
course just to give you one example that
we have what we call a labour gain
sharing program and the way that works
is that each each team gets a labor
budget to take care of the work that
they need to do so every week and every
month they know how much money they had
to spend to pay for labor if the team is
able to get the job done and not spend
all of that labor what's left over is
divided up among the team members so
it's like a bonus program that people
know if they work efficiently if
somebody calls out sick and they don't
have to call him as an extra person if
they can manage that together as a team
and still get the job done then you know
they get to keep the difference between
the labor budget and what they say that
kind of program would be great if we
could figure out how to do that for you
know our green mission as well
yeah you're right so to come on
thank you well that was quick so you
know again if nothing else let's let's
kind of eliminate this idea of waste
because we can't afford it there's just
you know there's not enough resources on
the planet to have waste any longer we
need to figure out how to recharacterize
it reuse it as something that can be
food for something else you know I apply
that to recycling as well you know a
steel can is food for another material a
plastic bottle is food for another
process or another material so really
there shouldn't be anything there's very
little in fact the the definition the
EPA definition of zero waste means
ninety percent of your material is being
diverted so they're allowing a ten
percent like we don't know what to do
with it there's no other solution yet so
you're allowed to have ten percent waste
my my counter to that is we can't afford
ten percent ways so what are we doing to
you know invent or create alternatives
to those ten percent materials that you
know can be composted can be recycled
can be reused whatever it happens to be
so I guess that's that's the end of my
formal presentation karamay I don't know
how I'm doing in terms of time but now
we can have QA and Justin you catcher
ah that's a great question and that's
that's really
you
you